is that why writing on a legal pad for
you is like a better process because
you're okay with it being messy right
there
yeah yeah and then when it goes into
sort of type format
you want it to be more in line and it's
like a signal to you well i think it's
it's um it's kind of it's not to
make it sound all like but it's kind of
like sketching before painting
you know it's kind of like let me draw
this out see what it's going to be
now i'm going to put paint on the canvas
so
if i if i know the bare bones of the
story
and i write with just the bare bones
then
other ideas are going to come in other
things are going to happen
sometimes i will find that my bare bones
are wrong
and that maybe i found a better better
bare bone or maybe i find that
that bare bone it was one thing in in
bob berry's things
it was actually part of the 11 000 word
thing that i it was great you know
i never got to write like this it was
like oh wow i'm writing well i'm going
to describe
every inch of this room you guys are
going to know everything about this
it's going to be great and
then
i'm like yeah this is just way too much
it's way too much you don't need this
but you have to have some kind of fun
writing it's got to be some kind of like
it's a like i enjoy it i never
it's never hard i mean it's sometimes
hard to get going
but i 20 minutes
i look at the first 20 minutes as
warm up like i am i don't just sit down
and then uh what am i doing okay i open
up i kind of look at stuff that's the
great thing about having the program
read the book
because then i can sit back and have it
read the last
chunk back to me and then it kind of
gets me into the
wrong then sometimes it'll i'll hear it
say like i use the word dome way too
many times
hit the dome like five times and i'm
like why am i saying dome so much
for someone's head yes and i'm like an
insider dome
outside a dome over a dome honest dome
top
just dome dome dome i'm like i gotta get
rid of these domes
but it's uh but you don't know until you
you have it
um and again maybe it sucks
sorry what was the name of this program
uh scribner
oh okay i've heard of that yeah okay and
so it will then
read back to you what you've typed oh
and it's a monotone sort of
yeah it's a voice it's just yeah
they have put in breaths oh nice so you
can actually
hear the robot taking her breath here
and there and i think it reads
um things in quotes at a slightly faster
pace than
the other stuff so for dialogue i think
it does speed it up a little bit
but um yeah i definitely caught stuff
that
because i remember having i always had
table reads of everything for vampire
mob
and i would record it because i would
always catch stuff
when i listened to the recording and
then i did one i had a
a screenplay called sue happy that the
filmmakers alliance um did a reading of
and they brought in
they had casting director they brought
in 25 actors it was a
giant ensemble thing it crushed
and it was the only time i ever got to
see one of my screenplays like
almost brought to life like it was a
staged reading
but um but it's
that is the reason i think that that'll
be the next book because i know
i know what that story does to an
audience
so i know what it can do in book form
do you have a ritual for like okay
you've copied up
you're you're waiting is there like this
ritual to listen to the scrivener notes
yeah
uh well one thing i i always listen to
this i have a nine i have an eight hour
and 49 minute long playlist of fats
waller songs
that's why i wrote a lot of songs um and
i have been listening to that
for over a decade um because
it i know all the music really well so i
don't listen to it
but it occupies the part of my mind that
can think of something else to do
so i always have that on and only
i had to change to tool the band tool
for a sequence i was writing and i just
like i couldn't get it with fat's waller
i
never had any problem and i'm like i
need something a little i'm like
tool and it was perfect it was exactly
exactly what i needed but uh
yeah coffee water make sure to drink
water everybody it's important
and um headphones
and i always write at home i never write
in any
coffee shops or anything like that just
because i can close out enough of the
world with loud headphones and i have
tinnitus so i always hear
ringing uh 24 hours a day seven days a
week so
um when i have those on it
there's something about 1930s music that
that hits
the frequency that buries my tinnitus a
little bit
wow except for when maynard sings
i don't know well like there's a
confusion
there's one song that's a little much
but
though they have a new album yeah fear
fear inoculum
as do the pixies oh that's great
what makes a great story joe what makes
a great
story uh i think
i like roger ebert's uh
take on it it's when you don't remember
where you parked your car
i think that's really good yeah when
you're in
when you're in the theater and you're
watching the movie if you don't
if you can't think where your car is
parked that's a good movie
and i think uh for a story
it's different for everybody i mean
my wife watches stuff that i don't watch
and vice versa
and she loves the historical
drama stuff and i'm not so much with the
historical drama stuff
um but she and she's like it's just like
candy
you know it's you know it's romance and
i'm like okay that's great i don't want
any candy
i guess i don't but like i watch bob's
burgers i love bob's burgers
i think it's a great show um
uh and it's really just a dysfunctional
family
it's all like every other classic sitcom
in the history of everything
and they just have a more grounded take
than the simpsons on
that genre was the brady bunch
dysfunctional
the brady munch on screen
i guess technically
sort of not not like now
i don't know really pretty perfect all
the family was
really the beginning of like anything
close to truth getting on television so
good times good time yeah it was great
all the normal air stuff
and they recently did a live reading or
live
reenactment and they built the sets and
jimmy kimmel had them do an episode on
the family an episode of the jeffersons
and they had to bleep
part of it because you can't say that
word on tv anymore
and to hear all the stuff that r.g
bunker said that you can't say on tv
anymore and maybe it would be more
useful to hear it on
tv now so people could understand what a
bigot is
right out of the gate that's a good
point because it was such a great
dynamic of
him playing off for getting me rob
reiner's character as the meathead
yeah and and this politically active
outspoken young person against
this old school bigot and then you have
the the co-dependent peacemaker edith
you know who just wants to make them
happen and the thing is if you watch
that show
there are episodes that don't leave the
living room
like that is doesn't happen a lot there
aren't a lot of shows that do that like
barney miller was one of those shows
that
you know you'll have more than one
you'll have the work set and have the
home set
on all the family was pretty much just
the living room in the kitchen once in a
while you'd see a bedroom
maybe the front porch and then maybe
you'd go to the jefferson's once in a
blue moon
but almost all of it was like a stage
play
what about welcome back cotter did they
leave the classroom yeah they did oh
they did oh yeah here and there they did
yeah because they think they did the
hallways
let's go back through all the seven
issues
uh but i think barney miller was genius
just in terms of the setup
because you have because and that's sort
of the way i thought about vampire mob
was that if you
have kind of like a few main characters
and you rotate in all these other
characters you can build a really big
world and it's also
a lot easier to schedule because if you
can
you know i was having actors come in and
do four hours so
you would write so they could get what
you wanted done in four hours
and then if you can set it up so they're
doing more than one
day in the story day then they can show
up in more than one episode
and it changes the dynamics of the whole
thing
what was the first story that you ever
saw i guess television or
film or even that you read where
it lit a an idea sparks an idea that
this is what i want to do i want to tell
stories
you know i never thought i would wanted
to do any of this stuff
i thought it was going to be a
photographer and
never thought i'd write a story or
anything ever
i did i watched a ton of tv as a kid
for some reason i knew some tv
terminology i knew tag as a kid
i knew the tag in a sitcom because i
watched a lot of talk shows and
heard people talking about sitcoms and
said that last thing at the end is
called a tag that you do and i'm like oh
cool
so i'm like an eight-year-old going oh
that's the tag dad huh good
i don't care um but uh
i was i guess i was just sort of aware
what interested me was that
barney miller and was in new york city
and all the family was in new york city
good times of things for chicago um
taxi new york city taxi was new york
city i always thought i was going to
live in new york city growing up
i thought it would be a divorce man
living with another divorced man trying
not to
drive each other crazy but uh
perfect strangers no no that's not a
couple okay
um but uh
i guess i was just so aware that they
were shot here
as a kid like i would always watch it
all the way to the end because you were
waiting for the next show to start so
you'd see every single credit and then
you'd see
shot at abc television studio or cbs
television studios and
i'm like so all of that is not in new
york and when you're a kid it's like
you know especially when when i'm an
hour i was growing up an hour and a half
north of new york and i'm thinking
oh barney miller he's just down just
down the train ride down in new york and
you sort of think of it that way and
then you think
oh so they have them all there and
they're in california where it's sunny
and they're pretending all this oh
that's interesting
you